You may have formed an impression of how animals
think and feel from Disney Movies or documentaries,
but the reality is startlingly different.
A new study has shown that sheep can recognize
human faces in photos, and can even recognize
their owner -- because that’s who the sheep
are personally familiar with on a day-to-day
basis.
And, despite having watched ‘Babe’ many
times as a child, I never thought sheep were
that smart, so this study made me feel pretty
sheepish!
In all seriousness, the internal lives of
animals are relatively shrouded in mystery.
The fields of animal behavior and animal cognition
have animals perform certain tests to quantify
levels of animal logic, reason, and emotion.
For example, in corvids, the bird family that
includes ravens and crows... they’ve found
some use tools in nature and can improvise
tools in urban environments... some have complex
problem-solving at at least the level of a
five-year old.
And some play.
Just for the sheer pleasure of it.
All kinds of animals are now being subjected
to intelligence tests of different kinds--racoons,
bats, bears, bees...you name it.
But, can we even classify all the different
pathways of communication in our fellow earthlings,
or do some of them exist outside our realm
of comprehension?
Do they have individual consciousness, or
even a collective hive mind?
We don’t know!
We don’t even know if insects can feel pain!
We really don’t know a lot.
Take communication for example.
Researchers hypothesize that cetaceans--dolphins
and whales--are capable of communicating and
receiving 20 times the amount of information
that we can with our hearing.
That also surpasses the amount of information
we can perceive based on vision, which is
our primary sense.
Not only that, but some scholars think that
because cetaceans can create and process such
complex sound, they could be capable of sending
auditory images to one another using their
vocalizations.
A dolphin wants to tell another dolphin about
a fish?
They might be able to send the image of a
fish to the other animal--through sound.
This is like if I wanted to tell you about
a tree and instead of describing it with my
words, I was able to use sound to project
a 3D hologram of that tree in front of you
for you to look at.
It’s NUTS.
They perceive sound as a complex, whole scene,
kind of like us when looking at a painting.
So them trying to understand our language,
which progresses word by word, would be like
us trying to watch a movie single frame by
single frame.
They even have distinct sounds that act as
names for individuals!!
Ok, I’m getting too excited.
Am I crazy or does this sound like the plot
of ‘Arrival’ to anyone else?
Of course, this doesn’t mean they’re sentient,
but if it’s this hard to understand communication
-- how can we assess the hidden beauty of
their cognition?!
We, as humans, are arguably the smartest species
out there...but that’s by our own measure,
limited by our ability to only frame the questions
we know how to ask.
I mean we don’t even fully understand our
own brains, much less the way a whale’s
works.
We’re limited by our own senses, by the
tools that we create to measure and explore
the world, and by our inevitably human-centric
version of the universe...because, well, we’re
the ones looking at it.
So.
Will we ever understand what it’s like to
live life as another species?
Mayyyybeee?
The next time you see a sheep staring, seemingly
vacantly, in your direction...maybe wave.
Say hi.
Make a friend.
And don’t assume you know what’s going
on in it’s head.
Hi fellow animals!
If you want more awesome animal knowledge,
bees just might be on the up and up!
Trace has got the knowledge for you right
here.
One last thing, if you’re ever swimming
near a dolphin, they can use their sonar to
communicate with each other, but also to ‘see’
inside your body because the noises they make
are a basically the same thing as an ultrasound.
Creepy?
Or insanely cool?
Thanks for watching Seeker.